>> First, probably the most important thing, is that we actually quarry whether
or not all the images have been loaded. If we don't do this little step, where
we query this.fullyLoaded, then what's going to happen is you can go through
your draw function trying to draw image data that hasn't actually been loaded
into memory. Of course, you'll just see nothing on the screen but it's generally
a good practice to let the entire thing load before you try to start working on
it. Next, we actually loop through all of the layers. And for each one,
determine whether or not it's actually a tile layer. Remember, we can actually
get object layers from the tiled setup. So, we need to make sure that we're only
rendering tile layers. From there, we actually create a convenient handle to the
data array. And then we walk through all the tile IDs inside of that data array.
If it equals zero, we go ahead and continue on because no tile needs to be drawn
there. If it's not zero, we go ahead and grab the packet information for this
tile.